la hambruna se cierne sobre el cuerno de
áfrica más de 23 millones de personas
padecen hambre extrema según oxfam y
save the children estas cifras
representan sólo a los escriben en
etiopía somalia y kenia un aumento de 10
millones desde 2021 varios factores han
contribuido a la crisis como la sequía y
la pandemia pero la invasión rusa de
ucrania ha empeorado la situación según
la onu entre 2018 y 2020 los países
africanos importaron el 44 por ciento de
su trigo de rusia y ucrania pero ahora
esos envíos se han prácticamente agotado
debido en parte al bloqueo ruso de los
puertos ucranianos
impidiendo a kiev exportar su grano los
precios del trigo en el continente
africano ya han aumentado un 45% según
el banco africano de desarrollo
encareciendo el coste de los alimentos
básicos y poniéndolos fuera del alcance
de millones de personas el banco ton en
advierte de un posible descenso del 20
por ciento en la producción de alimentos
porque los agricultores han visto
aumentar el coste de los fertilizantes
importados en un 300% la dependencia de
áfrica de rusia quedó demostrada en una
reunión de la onu celebrada en marzo la
mayoría de los miembros votaron para
condenar la invasión rusa de ucrania el
único continente que brilló por no
hacerlo fue áfrica 17 países africanos
se abstuvieron mientras que otros otros
optaron por no participar el temor a las
represalias rusas era evidente moscú
culpa a las sanciones occidentales por
la crisis alimentaria funcionarios de la
onu han mantenido conversaciones con
rusia para liberar las reservas de trigo
bloqueadas la falta de acuerdo podría
ser devastadora para el continente
africano